if you're in New York today you may be
wondering why every journalist is
walking around breathing into a paper
sack because Donald Trump is giving a
major televised address about the border
whatever he says you know it'll be fact
checked by liberal journalists who under
Obama
we're mysteriously AWOL but none of it
matters to Nancy and Chuck or Chansey
who've made the political personal after
all if you had agreed to what Trump
wants many times before why are you
rejecting it now the borders only gotten
worse since Democrats said this American
people are fundamentally Pro legal
immigration and anti illegal immigration
I voted numerous times when I was a
senator to spend money to build a a
barrier we simply cannot allow people to
pour into the United States undetected
undocumented unchecked but now their
story has changed
why has the situation improved hardly
but they recalculated they can agree
with Trump or decide that that is worse
than human trafficking and drug
smuggling in 2016 more than 20,000
unaccompanied children were stopped at
the Mexican border a 102 percent jump
from the previous year we don't know how
many got past the Border Patrol and ice
but that won't matter to Chansey because
human trafficking may be bad but not as
bad as cooperating with someone they
hate but this inaction isn't new in 2014
Obama was criticized when in one month
more than 10,000 unaccompanied kids were
stopped and released at the border a
doubling from the previous year the Dems
were criticized for ignoring the
warnings just as they should be
criticized now it wasn't an emergency
then and the Dems did nothing now
Trump's actually trying to do something
and they're just standing in the way why
they hate him they can't let him win
even if it saves lives of women in
children which is why the only wall
you're gonna see is Chuck and Nancy all
right I guess we should just go around
the horn here as they say I'll start
with you Dana
that's a lovely color thank you well
we're all wearing a little bit what
collaborative collaborative I'll just
stop it what should he say tonight well
this is a big deal to the if you think
of the communications toolbox of a
president I do this is the hammer ah
it's the strongest tool and he hasn't
used it here too for so he obviously
this is like his most important issue he
thinks this is the one thing that he
wants to address the nation from The
Oval Office on and so there's
significance in that it's an
eight-minute speech so you got to pack a
big punch into eight minutes it's his
chance to talk to all Americans right
it's not a campaign rally true the
chance for him to do all that I I don't
know what he can say that will move the
needle I looked at polling from the 2016
December 2016 to December 2018 we have
talked about the wall and immigration
non-stop for two years and still
opposition to the wall is 54% it hasn't
changed at all so can you do something
tonight in these eight minutes to make a
difference if that's that's it's
possible hmm interesting Jessie what are
your thoughts on this matter
well maybe the opposition to the wall is
how you phrase the question in the
polling I think when you talk about
border security right and fencing and
things like that you get a different
answer I think the media isn't scared
that he's going to tell lies I think the
media is scared he's gonna tell the
truth and the American people are gonna
listen and he's gonna be persuasive
because as you said these are very
powerful speeches is this first one from
the Oval Office
people are saying there's not a crisis
it's funny because this is from the
Washington Post Dana yes a few year days
ago after years of Trump's dire warnings
a quote crisis has hit the border but
generates little urgency and this is by
their chief national security
correspondent and chief border security
correspond
migrant families streaming in the United
States overwhelming border agents and
leaving holding cells dangerously
overcrowded what's the date on that
what's the date is January 5th all right
can I this is from December 16th 2015
unaccompanied minors are crossing the
u.s. southwest border and growing
numbers again sparking concerns that the
new influx of children would eventually
approach levels that last year prompted
the Obama administration
to declare a humanitarian crisis and so
here's why it's different because it
used to be Mexican adult males come yeah
you'd catch them and you send it right
back
now it's adults with children coming
from Central America and legally you
can't hold them together politically you
can't separate them and you can't send
them back quickly and there's about
60,000 coming across each month now
we've we've declared crisises the left
in the media I mean what we had a global
warming crisis we had an income
inequality crisis how many people did
that kill Juan
I mean opioid crisis student loan crisis
and you know you can make emergency
financial crisis right financial crisis
but look at this school shooting crisis
okay everybody would agree that that's a
crisis last year 29 people were killed
at school shootings in one year alone
just in Texas there were 32 illegal
aliens convicted of homicides that's
just in one state it's more deadly in
this situation than it is in almost any
other situation one two Jesse's Jesse's
pointing out that he's going against the
common assumptions on other networks
that there is no crisis do you agree
with Jesse which I think you should and
the Washington Post I don't understand
how people who are smart and capable and
thoughtful would even not see through
the charade this is the only crisis The
Washington Post I tell you what I'll
just say that was Obama get Islam is
stupid no Bhama didn't declare a
national Christ tonight when the
president speaks one of the options in
his toolbox is Dana said is that he
would declare that this is a national
crisis and a parent must give him some
powers and he could try to take money
out of the defense budget and the like
but is this 9/11 is this Pearl Harbor is
this the oh nine you know recession
depression no this is nothing the
invasion from the people who were in the
caravan before the midterms did we see
them exactly invade the United
yeah but two children died oh please so
what we have is by the way the numbers
are pretty clear apprehensions at the
border are going down down down down in
sac but President and Sarah Huckabee
Sanders were saying over the weekend oh
four thousand people these terrorists
attacked they know not true so nothing
should get done well this like what
but in 2015 you exactly what them said
no nothing gets done in fact you know
you know I think what we've seen is
Border Patrol did apprehend a terrorist
at the border once not wasn't a Mexican
boy though it was back in the 90s it was
at the Canadian border but there others
the big news is here the president's
finally starting to talk about a
humanitarian crisis because I think
that's where he can get out of his box
he is that box right now a political box
of his own making and the way that he's
trying to get out of it was you know oh
can I use this tool can I use that too
maybe if he starts talking about the
humanitarian suffering of people who are
coming to this country and how we
properly deal with it incomprehensible I
think he's tried to do that Emily but
when you're constantly called a bigot
for trying to create a stronger border
it's often a challenge when you have the
entire media against you absolutely and
I'll explain to you on how a capable and
thoughtful individual does think that
this is a profound crisis which is the
legal bar for this situation and for
declaring a national emergency which we
don't know if he's going to declare or
not but this is how for everyone on the
Left who is saying that there is a some
type of geographical situs containment
that happens at the border that's not
true for all the points that the Dems
say that they care about or that they do
care about they are all directly
directly attributable to the southern
border so the opioid epidemic for
example that kills 75,000 Americans per
year where do we think that comes from
what about drugs where do those drugs
don't come over the southern border look
can I just finish please because
actually there's a significant amount of
increase of heroin and opioids that do
flow over their southern border in
addition to the fentanyl and I just want
to point out the fact that for example
human trafficking which people throw
around lightly that's the third largest
criminal international industry on the
planet behind only drugs and arms that
is a thirty two billion dollar industry
and guess who pledged 50 million of our
tax dollars to combat it this year our
DOJ how is that not directly affecting
every single person and what is a
profound crisis the criminal justice
reform that everyone on the left and
hopefully the right to is supporting and
that and talks about a disparate impact
to minorities to low-income communities
where do we think the currency of these
gangs and the low-income communities are
coming from there is so much more there
are so many inner woven things that are
again attributable to that southern
border yes
it is absolutely a profound threat well
I'm gonna leave on that because we got
to move on well done Emily for
summarizing it